[Music]
problems in the air this Thursday night
the risks for people who can't escape
all that Wildfire smoke we are 100 200
times more pollution in the air
concerns about where it's headed next
a 78 million dollar prescription for the
health care crisis ottawa's goal to
train and retain workers
icing out you could send a ship straight
over the North Pole Nothing in Your Way
a summer without Arctic sea ice is
coming faster than we thought
and protect
protect the fight for lgbtq rights in
the face of rising hatred
foreign
[Music]
Canada's biggest city is still shrouded
in Wildfire smoke hazardous air quality
affecting millions of people in Canada
and the U.S good evening and thanks for
joining us for the third straight day
Canada's wildfires are having a
far-reaching effect it wasn't as
apocalyptic looking in New York City
today but it's expected to get worse
again and that City's 8 million
residents remain some of the hardest hit
many outdoor events have been canceled
at cities public schools are shifting to
remote learning tomorrow airports in the
region have delayed or canceled some
flights here is the scale of the
situation smoke or Haze to varying
degrees covered most of Canada at one
point today the worst of it lies in
Eastern Canada and Northeastern United
States where dense smoke shown here in
brown blanketed large parts of
Southwestern Ontario and several major
American cities New York state is
dispatching forest rangers to help in
Quebec fire Crews from other U.S states
are helping too what all of this has
done is focus attention on the
connection between wildfires and air
quality Eric Sorensen begins our
coverage tonight
construction sites stir up dust and
fumes at the best of times yeah
everyone's working with dust
exhaust now add smoke from wildfires on
top of that last two days
we're very bad you know like a smell is
like different like uh some snow game
and while some are putting on masks many
without are still working outside amid
some of the highest concentrations of
smoky air that several Ontario
communities have ever seen this is fine
particulate matters but over the
previous few days we are 100 200 times
more pollution in the air than we'd
normally expect to see and honestly it's
off our charts people with pre-existing
respiratory conditions are most at risk
and often these high concentrations can
trigger especially people with asthma
Canadian smoke has become an unwelcome
export South of the Border where New
York skyline was almost blotted out
smoke from the wildfires in Eastern
Canada blanket the region we continue to
see the smoke pour in from our Northern
neighbor the smoke has grounded or
delayed hundreds of flights and
threatened this weekend's Belmont Stakes
the final event in horse Racing's Triple
Crown we have instituted enhanced
measures to protect the horses and the
Riders and The Spectators smoke is
enveloping not only much of this country
in the United States it's now spreading
East over the Atlantic they're expecting
hazy Skies as far away as Europe the
smoke has swirled over Greenland and
Iceland in recent days and this modeling
shows Norway can expect haze from
Canada's wildfires anytime now it's all
been brought on by months of dry
conditions that have made Canada and its
immense forests a global Tinder Box I've
never seen it this dry in the last
hundred years if you look across Canada
I mean it's Canada Dry from coast to
coast the conditions suggest a dry
summer ahead and with global warming
more extreme Summers to come but it's
not all uphill at least in the next few
days winds are expected to shift in
densely populated Southern Ontario where
a little rain might help too Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
air quality in Toronto improved a bit
this morning it's deteriorating again
though many Ontario school boards
canceled outdoor recess and field trips
today daycares kept kids inside the
Toronto Zoo closed early Woodbine
Racetrack canceled live horse racing
today people who don't have homes
especially those who have breathing and
heart conditions have few options
Catherine Ward on the calls to do more
to help the most vulnerable
there's no amount of pollution that's
safe for our lungs close the windows
shut the doors
run the air purifier
this is the advice Canadians are being
asked to follow as dirty air chokes the
country but what if going inside is not
possible respiratory therapist Sarah
Hahn says it's a real problem for those
without housing they're the ones who are
the most vulnerable they're the ones who
don't have the tools needed in place to
have healthy lungs statistics Canada
estimates more than 235 thousand people
experience homelessness every year on a
given night there are some 25 to 35 000
people in need of a roof over their
heads experts say numbers tend to go up
when the weather gets warmer we know
that people who are unhoused have a
higher prevalence of cardiovascular and
respiratory disease Dr nihidasani works
with vulnerable people and hears about
their struggles firsthand you know I'm
hearing that it's not easy to breathe
out there people who experience
homelessness are quite ill and deal with
significant multiple medical conditions
typically all at the same time Federal
Minister Jeanie de kloe expressed
concern when asked about the issue it's
completely unacceptable that in a
developed country like Canada people
cannot have a roof over their head he
says there is money earmarked to help
but these resources are channeled
through Community organizations but
advocates
indoor spaces spaces while these
conditions linger I really wonder why it
isn't you know a normal practice to have
indoor spaces with clean air available
for unhoused people and the ability for
our governments to be able to scale up
in response urgently Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
in Quebec there are no new evacuations
happening right now and the premier says
the fire situation has stabilized but
more than 130 active fires are still
burning and more than 13 000 people are
out of their homes the number of
hectares burned this year is roughly 500
times the 10-year average parts of
Quebec may not get any rain until next
week Mike Armstrong reports on the
town's most at risk including one where
the Flames are just 500 meters away
[Music]
this is one of the spots that has
authorities most nervous crews are
digging a massive fire break at one end
of Centier a town of 1100 people they're
taking out the vegetation and then
spreading water on the earth
in a Facebook live post to the community
the mayor says they're hoping winds
don't pick up but that people should be
ready to move in case they do
now in the communities that have already
been evacuated the wind situation has
helped Flames came within 500 meters of
the town of narmetal but no homes or
structures were lost between water
bombers in the air and fire breaks on
the ground Crews were able to hold the
fire back different winds would have
meant a different story it was the flank
of the fire that was coming near the
community it was not the end of the fire
the forecast for the coming days doesn't
have much wind but it also doesn't have
much rain about 13 500 people have been
forced to leave their homes most of
those are unlikely to be able to go back
until Tuesday at the earliest
Cree community of ujjabugamu ordered an
evacuation Wednesday the deputy chief
says it did feel strange after following
news of wildfires across the country you
know just a couple of days ago we were
looking at that
and here we are it's on us
now as Northwestern Quebec struggles
there has been an improvement in the
East rain in recent days has dampened
fires enough that people in setsil were
able to return to their homes
many of the resources that were fighting
those fires are now being moved West
firefighters from France are arriving
Thursday they'll head there as well the
province is targeting the drier abitibi
region with just about all the resources
it can muster Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal
in BC about 80 fires are burning that
province has released its seasonal fire
forecast and drier than normal
conditions are expected right through
the summer
already the number of hectares burned
this season exceeds the total number of
hectares burned in 16 of the last 20
Wildfire seasons
the Donny Creek fire in northern BC is
still burning out of control it's
consumed more than 300 000 hectares of
forest the Cameron Bluffs fire near Port
Al Bernie BC grew overnight and it
closed the only major highway in the
area
we know a record number of Canadians
don't have a family doctor right now and
there are serious staffing shortages in
hospitals too some doctors in British
Columbia are sounding the alarm putting
a renewed focus on the state of some
emergency rooms and now the BC
government has responded there's some
assistance as well from the federal
government to help retain more health
care workers nitu garcha explains
Surrey Memorial is the only Hospital in
British Columbia's second most populous
city
and after a series of letters from
doctors here raising the alarm about the
management of patient care the province
has announced an immediate and long-term
expansion these are significant actions
but they are doable BC's Health Minister
says the expanded emergency and
maternity services will be immediate and
a long list of around 30 steps will also
help improve the situation right away he
personally gave me a guarantee
and I think that's a good thing that's
saying a lot coming from a physician
who's been among those most critical of
The Chronic issues for patients and
staff I'm very positive right now some
of the Surrey ER doctors we've talked to
say the province's promises fall
woefully short of the long-term needs
here by Dr Urban ipps says the announced
changes have made many feel hurt I hope
all the health Minister across the
country is going to look at us and
see what the ministry can do for their
citizens across the country the ER
crisis continues to affect patient care
I had one patient that stayed in the
department for 90 hours recently
awaiting care that never came patients
being resuscitated on the floor because
there is no stretcher to put them in
experiences like this have the Canadian
Medical Association welcoming the
federal health Minister's latest
initiative 78 million dollars in three
Investments including a national
Physician's registry today's
announcement will help Advance our
commitment to support the Recruitment
and Retention of our health workers the
crisis is not over when Canadians hear
an announcement of a number you know
multiply that by two to ten and that's
probably the amount of resources we'll
need to actually fix this problem he
says the longer it takes for more
commitments to fix the problems long
term the more costly it will become both
financially and in terms of patient
suffering need to Global News Surrey BC
in Ukraine five people are reported to
have died in that severe flooding caused
by a catastrophic Dam collapse on
Tuesday President Vladimir zielinski
toured the area today to assess the
damage and he met with officials to
discuss emergency plans for the more
than one thousand people displaced the
governor says about sixty thousand
hectares of land are under water most of
it on the Russian occupied side of the
danipro river rescue efforts are ongoing
and water levels are still rising in
some places it's left hundreds of
thousands of people without clean
drinking water and drones are being used
to deliver bottled water there's another
worry the flooding has dislodged huge
numbers of landmines sending them
Downstream
in France four children who were stabbed
in a park are now in stable condition
the stabbings happened at a playground
in honesty in a town in the French Alps
the children range in age from 22 months
to three years and Witnesses say at
least one of them was in a stroller an
adult was also critically injured police
intervened and the suspect was shot in
the legs police say he's a 31 year old
Syrian who had Refugee status in Sweden
plenty of Canadians are gearing up for
road trips this summer coming up where
gas prices are expected to go in the
next few months
foreign
summer is around the corner and with the
cost of living and airfare is still high
Canadians may think twice about price to
your vacations abroad road trips here at
home are another option that's drawing
more attention to what gas prices will
look like this season and gaviola has a
look at what to expect at the pumps
many budget conscious households are
hitting the open road this Summer
raspidar is taking his young family to
Cottage Country we have a plan for the
going to Tobermory on the 30th travel
plans bolstered by gas prices that are
down significantly compared to this time
last year the national average price per
liter is a dollar sixty that's down
about 50 cents from 2022 however you can
expect to pay a lot more in some parts
of the country like Metro Vancouver
where it's close to two bucks a liter
according to GasBuddy recent Decisions
by OPEC plus the cartel of oil exporting
Nations to cut Supply could push the
price of oil higher OPEC is playing a
dangerous game that it wants to drive up
prices in the short term but in the long
term it risks that policy spiraling out
of control this is Gas Buddy analyst
Patrick dahan's summer forecast most of
the summer most of Canada would be
between 1.45 to as high as 1.75
there's a big range because it's hard to
predict the severity of this hurricane
season or foresee unexpected events like
Refinery disruptions that can squeeze
Supply and boost prices but he figures
will likely in the summer with prices on
the lower end of his forecast I usually
try and fill up where I know it's cheap
this car Enthusiast and his family flew
abroad last summer everybody thinks that
you need to get away to like on a plane
or somewhere like that but truthfully
there's lots of stuff to do in in Canada
in the US that you could easily do by
car this year they're hitting the
highways and Country Roads and gaviola
Global News Toronto
spectacular side ahead one of the
world's most active volcanoes is added a
game
[Music]
the Kilauea volcano one of the most
active in the world is putting on a show
again on Hawaii's Big Island after a
three-month break volcanic activity was
detected again on Wednesday morning it
is contained within a closed space of
the Hawaii Volcanoes National Park
well there are new signs the global
climate crisis is unfolding quicker than
scientists expected new research shows
the Arctic is warming faster than ever
the data published in the journal Nature
says within the next few decades Arctic
summer ice will all but disappear
Heather York's West reports on what that
could mean
in the Arctic including Canada's North
ice is an important part of life for
polar bears and the people who call this
region home but a new study reveals the
Frozen sheets over these Northern waters
are actually disappearing faster than
previously thought and our window of
time to save that summer ice has now
closed we find that even in the um the
emission scenario with the lowest
emissions we still see an ice-free
Arctic by the middle of the century
since satellite records began
in nine summer Arctic Ice has already
decreased dramatically from a high of
more than 7 million square kilometers to
just over 4 million square kilometers in
2022 projection suggests that most of
that September ice will disappear within
the next few decades that means that you
could send a ship straight over the
North Pole Open Water Nothing in Your
Way future opportunities for shipping
and cruise ship travel will be tempered
by ecological costs loss of sea ice in
the summer puts Canada's already
vulnerable polar bear population in
further Jeopardy while threatening to
Forever change the way of life in
Northern Communities there's also
growing evidence that lower latitudes
will see impacts too there is a theory
that if you take away the sea ice that
changes the atmosphere over the Arctic
which some climate experts believe could
lead to a weakened puller Jet Stream So
a weakening jet stream would affect
weather patterns causing slower Moving
Systems which could lead to flooding and
more active weather it would also allow
strong areas of high pressure like a
summer heat Dome and a polar vortex to
dominate for longer leading to even more
weather emergencies
the loss of Arctic sea ice in the summer
now inevitable it's the rest of the year
we can still work to protect Heather
urich's West Global News Calgary
[Music]
political Pride next why representation
on Parliament Hill impacts all Canadians
[Music]
there's turmoil in New Brunswick's
legislature after the province announced
changes to a policy protecting lgbtq
students in schools the three changes
include not allowing students under the
age of 16 to officially change their
names or pronouns without parental
consent eight members of Premier Blaine
Higgs caucus refused to take part in
legislative business today because they
say they're extremely disappointed in
the lack of process and transparency the
premier says he is prepared to fight an
election over the issue if need be
it is pride months the time to celebrate
gay and trans identities yet around the
world there is rising hostility
targeting those communities from harsh
new laws and policies to open aggression
after so much progress in the past
decades it feels like a slide backwards
and Canada is not immune tonight turia
Israeli looks at the effect this is
having on those who run for public
office
pride month is a time to openly
celebrate
but for many the
world has gotten a little bit more
hostile to us that hostile is hanging
over celebrations
we've been reminded
by a rise and
anger hatred and ignorance the federal
government is spending 1.5 million
dollars to boost security for Pride
events Nationwide
parades libraries
and school board meetings have become
flashpoints for far-right protests this
year a us-based data tracker observed a
spike in anti-queer demonstrations in
Canada it's a type of polarization NDP
Randall Garrison thought the country had
left behind he ran in 2011 as a proudly
gay politician when I was first elected
I faced an onslaught of threats Garrison
is retiring this summer and sees history
repeat itself and that had basically
gone away until the pandemic and now
that level of rhetoric and threat has
increased again we will not accept going
back Blake desjarle is the first
two-spirit Member of Parliament and
thanks Garrison for Paving the way he's
also showed me the part that most
Canadians I think forget about which is
the distance we have to go still today
there are nine queer MPS serving on the
hill more than at any other time but
that's out of
333. it's a lot to sign up for online
vitriol and American style politics are
spilling into the Canadian discourse and
that climate may be keeping queer
candidates away we need to see some
strong political will that will enable a
culture for people who are like myself
who are black women who are in the lgbtq
community to feel safe enough to want to
even take on a leadership position and
maybe one day they'll be a trans Member
of Parliament that's something Garrison
also wants to see a more diverse
Parliament makes better laws which he
says better reflects all Canadians
Taria is read Global News Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this abandoned house in
Langley British Columbia thanks for
watching for our NASA we'll be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
again on Monday bye-bye
[Music]